uh
so
oh
is
[Applause]
[Applause]
some people didn't like the idea of
recording somebody's agony wrote
a bunch of kill jokes that's all
billiards are gonna watch the birthdays
studios not afraid of a scandal getting
caught up in it
you kidding scandals would they live for
i'd be out there too if i could be but i
got a family
and the job is what it is
what's going on josh you're all right
don't [ __ ] know
don't [ __ ] care get in there where do
i go
straight down this street building with
the officer out front
[Applause]
thanks
[Music]
oh
hmm thought you look more
i don't know professional
whatever get it don't worry olga we'll
fix this
trust me we'll be on schedule help's on
the way
finally we're late stevenson's been
asking for you all day
he's in his dressing room go talk to him
you wanted to see me i wanted you by my
side when my soul departs this world
i have no friends no family
only strangers as my company still uh
set on scroll in this brain dance i am
more determined than ever
you know what i think you're a true
rebel
a revolutionary i i don't understand you
want to give people something true
something real studio thinks they found
a sucker to make a fat buck on
but you're using them you're gonna
change the world
i never thought of it that way
i i am so afraid
will you pray with me a prayer of your
choice
fine sure
our father who our father who art in
heaven
hallowed be thy name hallowed be thy
name
thy kingdom come thy kingdom come
that will be done on earth as it is now
on earth
as it is in heaven give us this day our
give us this day our daily bread
and forgive us our dreams forgive us our
trespasses
as we forgive those who trespass we
forgive those who trespass against us
and lead us not to lead us not into
temptation
but deliver us deliver us from evil amen
amen
joshua this is it
my time has come i want you to walk with
me
i'd like you to wield the hammer
nail me to the cross please
no uh no way
then please just stay by my side
all right ew
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
father forgive them for they know not
what they do
[Music]
truly i say to you today you will be
with me
in paradise
[Music]
[Music]
you
father father into thy hands i commit my
spirit
[Music]
amen
probably my hardest gig that but i got
through it
what now
going home we're all asleep for two days
straight
be in touch about your compensation soon
be waiting for your call yep
later
you